[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر براكي
احييكم
في ايران بعد انتحار طفل العمامه والحرس
الثوري المتهم بالقمع يقر لاول مره بمقتل
المئات
صور ميسي
من العتمه وتخشى حصتها من الحرب
التشريعيه الاغلبيه الجمهوريه ترد على
بيضه لن نوقع شكا على بياض
وهات متابعونا معنا الليله ايضا
في المونديال السنغال تحلق بامال افريقيا
لدور الثاني والعالم يترقب صداما امريكيا
ايرانيا يتخطى الكره
[موسيقى]
مع مضيئه اكثر من شهرين على الاحتجاجات في
ايران لا يبدو ان مزيدا من الدماء سيشكل
اي فريق مع السلطات
محاكمه
تصلوا عقوبتها الى الاعدام وهي التورث في
قتل عنصرين من البسيج
وهو عدو الله ويعرف ضمن من يحاكمنا
من الاعدام شبه منعدد
كم عدد من يواجهون التهمه ذاتها في ايران
الفا شخص وحكم على سته منهم بالفعل
بالاعدام بانتظار نظر المحكمه العليا في
الاستئناف او الاستئنافات التي قدمها
الى حاله
تثير والتساؤلات السلطات تقول انه كان من
من هدد التجار لارغامهم على اغلاق محالهم
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر ان شاء الله
صلاه وجمع
للشعب
اذا شهران ونصف مرات من عمري الاحتجاجات
الايرانيه لكن ما شغل الايرانيين مؤخرا
كان من اطلق عليه لقب طفل العمامه المراهق
ارشيا امام جوليزادا البالغ من العمر 16
عاما اعتقله الامن لعشره ايام بتهمه اسقاط
عمامه احد رجال الدين
افرجها عن الفتاه لاحقا ولكن لم يمر يومان
على اطلاق سراحه حتى انتحر بحسب ما افاد
المجلس التنسيقي للمعلمين الايرانيين يوم
الاثنين اتهم مناسبون على مواقع التواصل
قوات الامن بتعذيب المراهق بشتى انواع
التعذيب خلال اعتقاله ما دفعه لاحقا
للانتحار بينما افاد مصدر مقرب من اسره
ارشيا لشبكه ايران انترناشونال ان قوه
الامن اقتحمت منزل العائله بعد فتره وجيزه
من الحادثه
وهددوها اذا ما تحدثت عن اي تعذيب عن اي
ترهيب تعرض له قبل وفاته يوم امس وري
ارشيه ترى في مدينته جلفا بمحافظه
اذربيجان الشرقيه شمال غرب الميلاد
[موسيقى]
الفراشه
للطفوله
الايرانيه ما ادى الى مقتل اكثر من 60
طفلا منذ بدء الاحتجاجات في منتصف سبتمبر
الماضي كما عبرت المنظمه الدوليه عن قلقها
البالغ حيل استمرار عمليات الذهب والتفتيش
التي تجري في بعض الملابس وقالت يوليوسف
ان المدارس يجب ان تكون دائما اماكن امنه
للاطفال كررت يونسف مطالبه الامين العام
للامم المتحده لقوات الامن الايرانيه
بالامتناع عن استخدام القوه غير الضروريه
او غير المتناسبه وخاصه عندما يتعلق الامر
بالاطفال والمراهقين سبق للامم المتحده
وان اعلنت انها نقلت مخاوفها مباشره الى
السلطات في ايران منذ وقوع الحالات الاولى
لضحايا الاطفال ردا على الاحتجاجات
وذكرت المنظمه ايران بانها طرف في اتفاقيه
حقوق الطفل وعليها ان تلتزم احتراما
وتطبيق حقوقهم في الحياه وحريه الفكر
والتجمع السلمي بصرف النظر عن هويتهم او
مكان وجودهم
ورغم المطالبات الدوليه راويه يستمر قمع
الاحتجاجات ولدينا اليوم حصيله رسميه
نتعرف عليها معك
السلطات الايرانيه اعلنت اليوم حصيله قتل
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه والتي وصلت في 3 بحسب
هذه السلطات قائد القوه الجوف فضائيه
للحرس الثوري امير علي حاجي الزاده قال في
تسجيل مصور ان جميع الايرانيين تاثروا
بوفاه مساميني حسب قوله واضاف المسؤول
الايراني انه لا يملك الارقام الاخيره
معبرا عن اعتقاده ان اكثر من 300 شخص
سقطوا في الاحتجاجات من بينهم اطفال لكن
الغريبه انه سماهم ضحايا وشهداء كما تشمل
الحصيله عشرات عناصر الامن الذين قتلوا في
المواجهات مع المتظاهرين بحسب السلطات
الايرانيه وتعد الحصيله الرسميه الاخيره
الاقرب الى رقم
416 شخصا الذي قالت منظمه حقوق الانسان في
ايران انهم قتلوا خلال قمع الاحتجاج
المنظمه افادت بان حصيلاتها تشمل ضحايا
اعمال العنف المرتبطه بالاحتجاجات على
خلفيه وفاه امينه اضافه للاضطرابات التي
شهدتها محافظه سيستان بلوشستان جنوب شرق
البلاد ومن بين من شملتهم ارقام الضحايا
الناشطه العربيه الاهوازيه عاطفه نعامي
التي عثر على جثتها في شقتها السبت الماضي
كفو
ووجدت جثه هذه الشابه مغطاه ببطانيه في
شرفه منزلها وبجانبها خرطوم متصل بصمام
غازي بالقرب من فمها السلطات الايرانيه
دفنتها الاثنين على عجل بمقبره في مدينه
كرج مع حضور عدد قليل من النساء من افراد
الاسره
تقرير
الا ان شقيقها قال من منفاه لموقع ايران
واير ان انتحار قال ان انتحار شقيقته
سيناريو ملافق وانها لم تكن تفكر في
الانتحار خاصه بعدما التحقت بالحراكس
نساوي في ايران
اتهموا السلطات في اكثر من مره باخلاقي
انباء انتحار انه شطائي او المحتاجين
لتنفي عن نفسها مسؤوليه قتل المحتاجين
والمتظاهرين كما انها تجبر اهالي القتل
على الاعتراف بان اقاربهم انتحروا او
سقطوا من مكان عال كشرفه انزلي مثلا وفي
تفاصيل العثور على جثه عاطفه بواسطه
اسرتها قال شقيقها ان الشرطه وخلافا لما
هو متبع تخلصت من بعض الادله في مسرح
الجريمه كما ان احد الضباط الحاضرين لمكان
الحادث قال للاسره ان الوفاه ليست ناجمه
عن انتحار وفقا لملاحظته
ومن اصله ينضم الينا يطهر عمار تسائي عضو
منظمه حقوق الانسان الاحوازيه حول هذا
الموضوع اهلا بك سيد عمار يعني غضب كبير
بايران بعد انتحار الطفل الذي يبلغ من
العمر 16 عاما ولا الذي يسمى بطفل العمامه
سالك السؤال الذي تصرخ وتناجي وتساله امه
كيف ادور الى هذا الحد من الذي حصل حتى
اوصله الى الانتحار
بطبيعه الحال ان هؤلاء الاطفال هم في عمر
الزهور وفي عمر الطفوله لا يدركون معنا
الاعتقال والاعتقال بهذه الصوره العنيفه
وجميع قوانين حمايه الطفل في الدول حتى
تمنع ضرب الطفل من قبل اهله وذوي من قبل
امه وامه وعبيد ولكن الطريقه الوحشيه
والهلال
ونقل هؤلاء الاطفال الى هذه الاماكن التي
في الحقيقه هي مرعبه السجون النظام
الايراني وخاصه سجون الامن الايراني هي
عباره عن اماكن مرعبه يغشاها الصغير
والكبير وجميع ابناء الشعوب الايراني هم
متخوفنا عندما يؤخذ هكذا طفل يسقط الى هذا
المكان هو يصاب بانواع التراما او الازمات
النفسيه التي سوف
عندما يتم الافراج عنه ويخرج من حاله
الصدمه يتبادر له او يتذكر ما حصل له او
ما حصل لغيره او الكلام الذي سمع او
التعذيب الذي تعرض له وانه في الكثير من
الحالات
يجبرون هؤلاء المعتقلين على ان لا يبوحوا
بما حدث لهم في السجون وعاده ما
يحاولون اخفاء الجريمه من اثار الجرح
الجراحات الوارده ومن ثم يطلبون صراحه
هؤلاء والواضح ان هذا الطفل هو كان سليم
ولا يعاني منه اي شيء ولكنه انتحاره يدل
انه تعرض الى تعذيب وحشي وربما حتى تعذيب
من نوع اخر او اهانات او تهديدات لذوي او
مخاوف وهو نقله الى المعتقل واحتجازه هو
يكفي ان يصيبه بحاله نفسيه لانه لم يكتمل
لم تكتمل همم
ولم يكتمل العاقل عنده ليميز همم الخطر
وبطبيعه الحال ان الاطفال في هذا العمر
يصابون بالظهر والخوف من هذه الاجهزه
سيد عمار يعني لاول مره يقرا النظام
الايراني على لسان امير زادا اللي هو قائد
بالحراسه الثوري ب 300 ضحيه وشهيد استعمل
هذه المصطلحات لماذا
هو وصف 3 هو وصفهم بالضحايا والشهداء
ضحايا والشهداء واحتقد انه اراد يرسل
رساله مبطنه الى قواته القمعيه القوات
رساله ولتعزيز ولرفع معنوياتهم المتدهوره
في هذه
الاحتجاجات التي شملت جميع مدن ايران
وجميع مناطق ايران لانه اليوم قرات على
تغريده لاحد الضباط المشرقين الذي غرد
فيها وقال انهم يشبهون جنود احتلال هو
يواجهون الناس احتلال وحالتهم حاله مزريه
لها واحتفظ ان هذا
الضابط او هذا القائد في الحرس الثوري
اراد بهذه بهذه التصريحات ان يرفع من
معنويات قوات القمع التي معنوياتها متدوره
جدا وانه ايضا صرح وصف ايضا مره اخرى
للمظاهرات والاحتجاجات باعمال الشقق ووصف
المتظاهرين بالمشاغبين وانه اراد يرفع من
من معنويات
الجنود والجنود المنهكين والقوات القمل
المنهكه التي تسرب اليها العجز اعتقد عن
احتواء هذه المظاهرات واما تصريحه بهذا
الرقم اكيد هذا 300 هذه اول مره ياتي
تصريح من مسؤول ايراني وخاصه مسؤول عسكري
ايراني بهذا التصريح هو اعتقد انه لجنه
تقسي الحقائق التي شكلت من قبل مجلس حقوق
على الانسان لا يفوتها هذا التصريح وسوف
تدونه في سجلاتها التي سوف تجمعها ضد
المنتهكين حقوق الانسان ومن ثم حتى هناك
احتماليه لرفعها الى المحاكم الدوليه
لمعاقبه
للمعاقبه القانونيه للمجرمين والمنتهي
حقوقها الانسان وحقوق الاطفال وحق النساء
اذا من اصله شكرا جزيلا لك سيد عمار كساء
يعضو منظمه حقوق الانسان الحواسيه
[موسيقى]
360 ايضا
تركيا تبقي ساعه الصفر للتواغلي في سوريا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد دعم حل فنيته لاوكرانيا
ثابت ولن يتغير هذا هو تعهد وزراء خارجيه
الدول الحلف في اليوم الاول من اجتماعهم
في بوخاري
وسطا موجه من الهجمات الروسيه
للاراضي الاوكرانيه
حمل فعليا لغه تتحدث رغ
[موسيقى]
عندما يتعلق الامر بمنطقه البحر الاسود
فهذه منطقه ذات اهميه استراتيجيه حيويه
بالنسبه لنا ولحلف شمال الاطلسي حول روسيا
اجزاء من البحر الاسود الى منطقه حرب لقد
راينا صواريخ قادمه من السفن الحربيه الى
المدن والبلدات الاوكرانيه وسنقوم بتعزيز
وجود الناتو من البحر الاسود الى بحر
البطيخ
كان تصريح بنت لافتا لكن الاخطر كان تصريح
الامين العام لحلفي الناتوينس توتنهام بعد
ان ضغط على الجرح الروسي الذي فجر الحرب
واكد ان اوكرانيا ستنضم الى الحلف يوما
معا
يجب تهيئه ظروف لسلام دائم يضمن ان تكون
اوكرانيا دوله مستقله ذات سياده يجب علينا
الاستمرار في تقديم الدعم العسكري لها لذا
فان رسالتنا من بخارستيه سوف يستمر في
الوقوف مع اوكرانيا لاطول فتره ممكنه ولن
نتراجع عن ذلك
قد يكون الشتاء العدو الاقصى لاوكرانيا
وقد لا يكون انها مساله يجزم بها هذه
المره من يحسب خطوته مليا متداركا ما
سيجلبه فصل الثلوج بكل ابعدته اذن محللون
عسكريون قالوا ان الشتاء قد يغير مسار حرب
باكملها لماذا باختصار ان الابعاد
اللوجزتيه اللوجستيه منسيه اذا احيانا رغم
ان الحركه الجغرافيه لا تبعد عن كونها
قدرا يجبر اي من الاطراف المتحاربه على
تغيير الخطه بعد ان يفوت الاول هذا يعيدنا
الى القوه العسكريه
والاعداد سيقف الجنود مكتوفي الايدي
باسلحتهم الضخم امام التقلمات الطقس الذي
يصعب قتال المشاه والمدرعات ناهيك انه
يعقد عملي
اذا تكتيكات الرئيس
شبه واضحه للعين فبعد الانسحاب الروسي من
غير بخيرسون وعبور نحو الشرق والتراجع
العسكري
ان تصب جهدها باي طريقه لضرب عزيمه
الاوكرانيين واغرقهم بظلام دامس وبردا
قارس خطوه يراها حلف شمال الاطلسي محاوله
روسيه لاستخدام الشتاء كالسلاح حرب ضد
الاوكرانيين وعليه اجتمع الحلفاء في
رومانيا
تشمل الوقود والامدادات الطبيه لتجبر تلك
ضربات الروسيه شركات اوكرانيه الكهرباء
على تقنين امداداتها بواقع 60 بالمئه في
كاف لتبقى النسبه المتبقيه وحدها من تصارع
تربيه احتياجات البنيه التحتيه الاساسيه
للاستهلاك اليومي وامام سقيع الشتاء حيث
الوجه يجدد الرئيس الاوك في فولودي
ميرسيلينسكي دعوه شعبه للتكاتف معنا
لتجاوز الازمه علما ان اسبوعا وحشيا اخر
ينتظرهم على احدث تعبيرهم
لضربات جديده نحن نعرف هذا على وجه الدقه
وطالما كانت لديهم صواريخ فلن يهداوا
للاسف لكن قدرتنا على مساعده بعضنا البعض
والاعتناء بمنهم في اصعب الاوضاع كبار
السن والاسر التي لديها اطفال ومن فقدوا
منازلهم واقاربهم بسبب الحرب مساعدتنا
المتبادله هي احد عناصر الحمايه من
الارهاب وهي مصدر قوتنا
استهدافي روسيا قلبنا التحتيه وقتل
المدنيين بردا يريد بوتن ان يصنعه هو
عميقه بين الحكومه الاوكرانيه وشعبها
ليضغط على السلطه ثم تلجا للدبلوماسيه
خاضعه لمطالب الاوكرانيا لكن المؤرخين
التاريخيين يرون ان ذلك لم يجدي نفعا
مستذكرين ما جرى في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه حينما اعتمد الغرب على القذف
الاستراتيجي سواء مع اليابان او المانيا
فكلهما كان رد شعبه بالالتفاف حول السلطات
اجمالا يسعد بوتن وجنوده بتحقيق مكسب اخر
على ايجابها الشرقيه لا سيما الدم باس
وايضا يوازن الرئيس الرودادا فعل الغربي
ويقيس صبرهم اما ميدانيا فان اجواء الشتاء
حينما تقلب المشهد للابيض ليس بالضروره ان
توقف الحرب لان الارض تبقى صالحه لسير
الاليات حتى فوق الثلج والجليده لكنه
مقيادون بالطرقات المعبده وهذا امر يجعلها
هدفا سهلا خاصه مع التكنولوجيا الجديده
المستعمل التي شكرا يا اما يعني بان تجاوز
الساقيه بالنسبه للجنود مقدورون عليه
بالمساعدات والحزام الشتوي لكن الحبكه
الحقيقيه للمعركه الاكثر تعقيدا لم تبدا
بعد ولن تكون اساسا في هذا الطقس مرحله ما
بعد الشتاء هي الاقصى والاصعب بلا شك
فتجاوز الثلوج بالمدرعات حتما اسهل من
ذوبان كل تلك البحيرات المتجمده فالذوبان
والوحل الذي يتشكل بسببه هو اكبر عائق
لتقدم الجيوش خاصه في حاله المناوره
والهجوم وما بينهما يعزز الوحل استخدام
المدافع لكن الهدف الروسي باسترداد كل
اراضي الاقاليم الاربعه سيجعلها تختار
الهجوم واذا كنتم تذكرون تلك القريه التي
اختارت ان تغرق نفسها مقابل الا يدخل
عدوها على ارضها متجهها النحو العاصمه كاف
وفعلا نجحت حينها دامي داف باعاقه القوات
الروسيه فيضان متعمد يجبرها على التحول
نحو تضاريس اصعب لذا يريد الرئيس بوتن كسب
الوقت الان حتى ولو على حساب استنزافي
صواريخ الذكيه فقط لتحضير القوى العسكريه
واعاده تعبئه مخازن وذلك تحذيرا لمرحلتي
ما بعد الشتاء وما بين اول الربيع واخره
قد يكون هذا الفصل المزهر اشد الامامه
ندفع ثمن باهظا لهذا الانتصار لكن يجب الا
نتراجع وان يحاول حتى النهايه
لا كهرباء ولا تدفئه في نوفمبر اعيش في
شقه في منزل قديم من طابقين يشغلون
التدفئه ليلا عندما تكون هناك كهرباء وهي
متوفره لمده اربع ساعات في اليوم
هذا كان شتاء اوكرانيا في حربها لكن هل
تسلم جارتها مولدوفا من انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي
الاجابه الاولى
حينما قصفت روسيا خطوط الامداد في
اوكرانيا وقطعت معها الكهرباء عن شوارع
الدوله الصغيره في اوروبا الشرقيه
البلاد ان الحرب تهدد امدادات الكهرباء
والغاز معربه عن قلقها من ان يعرض هذا
الوضع سلامه المجتمع وامه للخطر
هذه الدوله التي استقلت عن الاتحاد
السوفياتي موضوع عام 91 نزل مدنيها او
نزلوا في سبتمبر الماضي الى الشوارع
احتجاجا على ارتفاع الاسعار وطلبوا باسقاط
الحكومه وقبل اشهر وصل الشبح الحرب الى
تلك البلده الواقعه بين رومانيا واوكرانيا
حينما طالتها سلسله انفجارات في عاصمه
اقليم ترانسليستريا الانفصاليما اثار
مخاوف حينها بانها قد تكون الهدف التالي
لموسكو ان مولدوفا شاركت اوكرانيا في
عتمتها لكن هل ستركها ايضا في حربها في
الحقيقه هنا كما خوف من ان تجر مولدوفا
بالفعل الى
الحربون لصحيفه ميوزك مع قولهم ان المرحله
الاولى من الحرب واتجاه الروس نحو مقولايف
وصولا الى اوديسا كان قد يعني انه اقتربوا
من ترانزستيا وبالتالي خوضها للحرب ذلك
لذا تلاشى خطر الدخول في المعركه وهذا لا
يعني ان التحديات خمدت لان مولدوفا التي
تعتمد على الغاز الروسيه بنسبه 100% ومع
اعرابها عن موقفها تجاه الازمه ردت عليها
روسيا بمعاقبتها وخفض 30% من اكتوبر من
غازيها في اكتوبر
اضافيا الى
56.5% بحلول الاول من ديسمبر
الى حد ما استقبلت العدد الاكبر من
اللاجئين نسبه الى عدد سكانها وفي الوقت
ذاته لم ترسل جنودها للميدان وبحسب محلل
فان العقوبات روسيه ستجعلها اكثر قربا من
دول الاتحاد الاوروبيه
الاوكرانيه زعيم الاغلبيه الجمهوريه في
مجلس النواب الامريكي كيف رد على الرئيس
ان المجلس لن يوقع شيكا على بياض
لاوكرانيا وذلك بعدما قال الرئيس الامريكي
في وقت سابق من اليوم ان دعم اوكرانيا
وكرونا يجب ان يكون على راس الاولويات
من واشنطن مراسل العربيه
الجمهوريه ترد على بايدا لن واقعه شيكا
على بياض هل نشهد اولى المشاكسات بين
الحزبين
بعد الانتخابات النصفيه طبعا
اليوم هو تاكيد على موقفه السابق بانه لن
يوقع
مساله مهمه جمهوريون عندما يطالبون
بالتدقيق هم لا يعاردون تقديم مساعدات
لاوكرانيا هم يريدون فقط التدقيق لكي لا
تتكرر تجربه العراق وافغانستان كما يقولون
عندما تبخرت الكثير من الاموال بل بالعكس
همم مايكل مقال وهو كبير الجمهوريين في
لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه في مجلس النواب
ومن المرشح ان يكون رئيس هذه اللجنه في
الدوره المقبله طلبه منذ يومين فقط اداره
بيرد بتسريع تقديم كل ما يريده او يحتاجه
الاوكرانيون من اسلحه لمواجهه او لتفادي
ان تطول الحرب وشدد على صواريخ الطاقه
التي قال ان الاوكرانيين بحاجه لها لكي
تصدر للمسيرات الايرانيه التي قال ان
وجودها في همم جزيره القرم هو خطر في هذه
الحرب همم ايضا يجب ان تذكرت عندنا
الامراء قليلا كان هناك مزادات من قبل
الجمهوريين على الديمقراطيين بدايه الغازه
الروسي بان يقدم المزيد وان يسرع بتقديم
المزيد من الاسلحه التي يحتاجها
الاوكرانيون في حربهم هذا موقف واضح همم
الجمهوريون يريدون فقط التدقيق بموضوع
المساعدات لكي لا تذهب الاموال تتبخر كما
يقولون او ان تذهب الى الى جهات مستفيده
ولكن لا ليس ليس لها مصلحه بان ينتصر
الاوروبيون نفسه ايضا قال بان على
الامريكيين من الاهميه للشعب الامريكي ان
يفهم ان انتصريين بهذا الحرب ضروري لانهم
اذا هزموا ستنظر الصين الى تايوان وسيكون
ذلك بايضا في مصلحه ايران ومصلحه كوريا
الشماليه طيب نفهم منك حسين بانه همم هذه
المشكله وكانها جزء من مشاكل عديده بين
الطرفين الان بعد الانتخابات النصفيه خاصه
هل اوكرانيا هي اكبر هذه المشاكل بينها
في الحقيقه طاهر لا ايضا يجب ان نشير انه
منذ يومين جيمس كومير وهو نائب جمهوري في
مجلس النواب وهو عضو لجنه الرقابه في
المجلس ومن المرشح ان يكون ايضا رئيس هذه
اللجنه في الدوله المقبله قال انه هناك ما
بين 40 الى 50 قضيه مهمه سيحقق فيها
الجمهوريون منها قضيه
منها قضيه الانسحاب من افغانستان الذي يسر
ويصفه الجمهوريون بانه كان انسحاما كارثيا
قضيه ايضا كيفيه تعامل الاداره الامريكيه
الحاليه مع موضوع الحدود الجنوبيه مع
المكسيك هناك قضايا خلافيه كثيره في
الحقيقه ما بين الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين
ويسعى الجمهوريون يعني يضعوا عثرات امام
اداره العاملين المقبلين وهذه كل الامور
صلتونا الضوء عليها طبعا هناك امور من
المراجع عن يتفقوا عليها مثلا الموضوع على
الانفاق العام قالها اليوم همم مكاننا وهو
زعيم الاقليه الجمهوريه في مجلس الشيوخ
انه اتفق مع كارثه على موضوع عن ان يمرر
همم الميزانيه العامه الانفاق العام
ولانيا ولا ان يمرر فقط تشريع مؤقت هم
يريد ان تجنب ذلك ولكن هناك خلافات كثيره
هناك دعاوي لاسيه من القاعده الجمهوريه
بان يتم التحقيق مع هنتر بايدن حتى بان
يتم هناك همم يعني يكون هناك همم عزل ايضا
لعدد من همم الموظفين في اداره الرئيس
سبايدا وحتى هناك من يطالب باجراءات لعزل
الرئيس مرضى النفسي ولكن طبعا هذا امر همم
صعب جدا لكن هناك مطالب لدى الجمهوريين
وخاصنا القاعده الشعبيه ومن المؤيدين
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب كرد على ال-
ال- الاجراءات العزل اللي تتعرض لها دوره
تراب خلال الرئاسته هناك خلافات كثيره من
المتوقع ان نشهد المزيد منها في الايام
المقبله معك اول باول حسين همم
معك بهذا القدر انا والزميل راويه مراسل
العربيه من واشنطن حسين تحياتي لك
[موسيقى]
الى الوضع في مناطق شمال سوريا الان التي
تعيش حاله من القلق والترقب خشيه من تدخل
بري للقوات التركيه مع تواصل تهديدات من
انقره وعلى الرغم من التحضيرات الدوليه من
اي عمليه عسكريه تركيه بريه في الشمال
السوري اعاده انقره اليوم التاكيد على
انها ماضيه في تحركاتها العسكريه المتحدث
باسم رئاسه التركيه ابراهيم اكد ان التوغل
برا قد يبدا في اي لحظه وان العمليات
العسكريه ستستمر على ان تحدد انقره زمانها
ومكانها ومنذ ايام اطلقت انقره سلسله من
الضربات الجويه والقصف المدفعي المتواصل
ضد مواقع لحزب العمال الكردستاني ووحدات
حمايه الشعب في شمال العراق وسوريا بعدما
اتهمتها بالمسؤوليه عن تفجير اسطنبول في
الثالث عشر من الشهر الجاري كما شلت القوه
التركيه خلال السنوات الماضيه ثلاث عمليات
عسكريه في شمال سوريا حينها ارسلت ودعمت
وشكلت فصائل سوريه مسلحه مواليه لها
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
والى الجنوب من الحدود التركيه طلبت قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه من روسيا التدخل لمنع
هجوم تركي بري ضد مناطقها وفق ما قال
قائدها العام مظلوم عبد اضافه قائد قصد
انه طلب من قائد القوات الروسيه في سوريا
ضروره ايقاف الهجمات تركيه خاصه مع تزايد
التهديدات واسرار تركيا علشان عمليه
البريه فيما يتعلق بالولايات المتحده قال
مظلوم عبدي انهما زال يخشى هجوما بريا
تركيا على الرغم من التاكيدات الامريكيه
وطلب واشنطن برساله اقوى مع الحديث عن
تعزيزات تركيا غير مسبوقه على الحدود عبد
دعى الولايات المتحده الى التلويح بشيء
ملموس اكثر لكبح جماح تركيا بعدما قال انه
تلقى تاكده واضحه من كل من واشنطن ومسكو
بانهما تعارضان اي دخول تركي برا عبر
الحدود لكن رد واشنطن جاء محبطا بعد ان
اكد البنتاجون قبل نحو الساعه بانه قلص
الدوريات المشتركه شمال سوريا بسبب
العمليات العسكريه التركيه لم يفوت عبدي
تحذير انقره من انه في حال نفذت تركيا
تهديداتها فهذا سيعني توسيع دائره الحرب
لتشمل كامل الحدود السوريه مع تركيا فيما
وصفها عبدي بمعركه وجود حتى الان ومنذ ان
اطلقت انقره ضربتها الجويه في العشرين من
الشهر الجاري قتل 75 شخصا بينهم 10 مدنيين
بينما كانت الغالبيه من مقاتلي قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه والتشكيلات التابعه لها وقوه
النظام وفق المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
[موسيقى]
معنى الالمانيه
360 اي رساله ترسلها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه للاكراد للمقاتلين منهم تحديدا
في الشمال السوري عندما تقوم بتقليص عدد
الدوريات المشتركه في شمال سوريا
مساء الخير لكم مشاهدي العربيه اينما
كانوا اعتقد هذه الرساله اذا تم التعاطي
معها بالطريقه التي يرغب فيها صناعه
القرار سيكون لها تدعيات في الداخل
الامريكي ايضا الرئيس الامريكي قال لن
نفعل ما نفعله ترامب
وسيكون لذلك تاثيرات حتى على السياسه
الداخليه حينما هبت الديمقراطيين
والجمهوريين منتقدين ومهاجمين قرار رئيس
رئيس الامريكي ترامب الانسحاب ما تحالي
تركيا لنجوم واحتلال لاسيريكانيه راس
العين الابيض ده اللي وصل الامر وربما
للمره الاولى في تاريخ القرد ان يستقيل
وزير الدفاع الامريكي جرش وايضا جورج
استقاله احتجاجا على القرار الامريكي هذا
القرار لن يكون له تدعيات فقط على الداخل
في شمال انه ربما يؤدي الى فتح المجال
امام تركيا للغزل جديد وبالتالي نتائج
كارثه
هذا هو السؤال هل يصل الى حد اعطاء ضوء
الاخر للاخضر لانقره لتقوم بعملياتها او
يمكن ان تخفف العمليات تقلص الدوريات
المشتركه امريكا مع قصد ولكن دون ان تسمح
او تعطي الضوء الاخضر هي وروسيا لتركيا
بالتوغل بره
يعني هل يعقل ان تعترض الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وروسيا على تركيا
وتقوم تركيا بعد ذلك باي عمليه عسكريه
الطرفين يحاودان تركيا في بعض القضايا
لكنهما يعرفوني ان نتائج الكارثيه التي
همم سينجب عن اي هجوم تركيه ليس على
الصعيد الانساني فقط انما على صعيد ما
يمكن ان همم يسطر عنه يعني تحركات الدواعش
ووجود اكثر من 12,000 داعش في في سجن
القوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وجود مخيم الهون
الذي [__] يعني اوائل
52 دوله هذه البقعه على الارض هي التي
تجعل الولايات المتحده تستمر في التحالف
الذي تقوده ضد داعش والتي يعني يقولون
بصوره مستمره ان قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
الخلفاء تركيا لا تعرف هذه اللغه تركيا
يعني يجب ان يكون هناك موقف حازم وحازم
وموقف ربما يؤدي الى خاصه فيما يتعلق
الملف الاقتصادي لان اردوغان يعني اردوغان
وايضا ايران يعني يهربان من الازمات
الداخليه
عندما يقول الاكراد اذا حصلت عمليه عسكريه
تركيه سنحول هذه الحرب الى حرب على طول
الحدود وحرب وجوديه ماذا يقصدون بحرب
وجوديه على طول الحدود وهل يمتلك اكراد
سوريا فعليا
التجهيزات والقدرات العسكريه والبشريه
لقيام بهذا عمليه وحرب
الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي لم يكن يوما
فلسطينيين يملكون يعني اي قوه ربما يمكن
ان تقارن مع الاسرائيليين في الكثير من
دول العالم نفس الامر يعني قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه بالتاكيد لا تملك ما تملكه
تركيا لا على صعيد العدد ولا على صعيد
العديد لكن نحن شاهدنا ما جرى فيها التي
كانت تحوي اكثر من 500,000 نزح الان باكر
كره القدم قليله هناك تم تهجير مئاتنا في
سريري كاريرا استعين يعني لم يعد ربما
موجوده على مئات من كبار السن في المدينه
لهذا تركيا همم حينما قال جمال المظلوم
العبدي انها تستهدف الكرد وجديا هذه
المساله مستمره منذ همم 99 عاما يعني منذ
التوقيع على معاهده الاوزان وحتى الان
تركيا تستهدف الوجود الكردي قبل حزب لما
الكردستاني وربما سيستمر بعد حسب الكره
الثانيه الان ماذا سيفعله الكرد والعرب
وبقيه المكونات بالتاكيد سيستخدمونه كل ما
لديه من همم من الاسلحه وهي ليست ثقيله
كما يروج الاعلام من اسلحه او من القدرات
قتاليه ومن الاستعدادات التي قام بها ليس
في المناطق التي استهدفها في المناطق
المحتله على طول الحدود لكن ما اكلها من
ضمانات امنيه لتركيا لكي همم يقدموا لها
شيئا في المقابل توقف من خلالها هذه
العمليه مادام ينفون تورطهم في العمليه
الارهابيه الاخيره في اسطنبول
لم ينفوا فقط انا اقول لك قسم الدراسات
العلميه في البرلمان الالماني حينما اعتذر
على تركيا باطلاق الصواريخ من شمال شرق
سوريا قسم الدراسات العلميه في البرلمان
الالماني قال ان ان البحث الذي تم تقديمه
البرلمان لم يجد له المزاعم التركيه لم
يجد لها اثر حتى في الصحافه التركيه واكدت
الدراسه الصادره عن قسم الدراسات
ماده 51 من المتحده ان تهاجم الكردي
يطالبون
الطرفين الظالمين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه التركيه
اتفاقيات اكتوبر 2019 يعني ما الذي يملكه
تركيا نحن نحن نطالب العالم ان يرجع هذا
العدوان الذي يعني تقوم به دوله في حلف
شمال الاطلسي ما الذي يملكه هل من المنطق
من العقل ان يقدم القرد ذريعه من خلال
ارتكاب جريمه ارهابيه قالت المدنيين اليوم
اكد مره اخرى قائد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
قال هذه احلام البشير لديها ثلاث اشقاء
قتلوا مع داعش
وتزوجت من ثلاثه من الدواعش
شعوب الديمقراطيه يطالب بالتحقيق في هذا
الموضوع
رواياتكم انها تستغل ذلك رغم ان هتتهم
القوات الكرديه
شكرا على هذه المشاركه معنا نواف خليل
مدير مركز الكردي للدراسات تحياتنا اليك
شكرا
[موسيقى]
ازمه جديده في السودان
ستفاقم معاناه المرضى اكثر واكثر بعد قرار
بتحرير اسعار الدواء المستورد
جعل الالاف من الاسر غير قادر على الحصول
على الدواء خصوصا اصحاب الامراض المزمنه
محمد فراوله والتفاصيل
[موسيقى]
الحاج احمد صالح صوره من مقاس الفقري
والفقر المدفع الذي يكشر انيابه عن الاف
الاسري في السودان البلد الذي اصبح منها
كان بالمعانه في هذا البيت يجلس الحاج
صالح وكانه يلملم جراحهه بعد ما ادخله مرض
السكري الذي ينخروا جسده بسبب عدم مقدرته
في الانتظام على شراء الادويه لغلاء
اسعارها وعدم توفرها في معظم الصيدليه فلا
مال او دواء ولا وصفه طبيه ولا حتى طبيب
جدا جدا
تحرير اسعار الدواء المستورد
ومعها حظر تجمع الصياد الى المهنيين من
خطوره مثل هذه الخطوه قائلين لنا
ستؤدي الى مضاعفه اسعار الدواء الحاجه دي
طبعا انعكاسه على المواطنه السوداني في ظل
الوضع الاقتصادي البيعيشوا كل الشعب
السوداني هو يعني الجريمه بالصبغه الاصرار
والترص يعني كل ذلك ياتي تزامنا مع تدهور
الخدمات الصحيه في البلاد وانعدام اكثر من
1,000 صنف من اصل 10,700 مكون دوائيه
اختفت من الاسواق واتهامات للسلطات
بالتنصل المسؤولياتها تجاه توفير الادويه
المنقذه للحياه
توفر العلاج مجانا لانه في كل المنظمات
الحقوقيه في العالم المتحده والجهاد
المهنيه بالعلاج بالمرضى بكده
يعني اقروا و وضعت يعني
توجيهات وقوانين واضحه وصارمه انه العلاج
حق في 2019 بدات تسعير الدواء لهذا المرض
المزمن مقابل 18 جنيها سودانيا واليوم وصل
سعره الى 265 جنيها
واستتوقعات بوصول تسعيره الادويه لما يزيد
عن 500 جنيه ما يعني مزيدا من المعاناه
للمرضى محمد فروانه العربيه
وفي العربيه 360 ايضا صاروخ الصين انطلق
لاكمال المحطه الفضائيه الصينيه انطلق
وكان القمر في انتظاره
[موسيقى]
ا لمزاحمه الولايات المتحده على الرياده
في الارض او في الفضاء
انطلق اليوم لاستكمال بناء المحطه
الفضائيه
لثلاثه رواد اخرين علمتني محطه يونج
مع القمر في توقيت انطلاقه الصين اذا
قادمه وبقوه ان كان غيرها وصل القمر
فاستصل
غيرها بعد ايضا
[موسيقى]
الى تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360
حق
ل رئيسه في صندوق النقد الدولي كريستالينا
جورجيفا التي حذرت كذلك من ان السياسه
الصينيه كان لها تاثير كبير على الناس
والاقتصاد
الدوليه مزيدا من المتاعب للاقتصاد
العالمي الذي لن يدور الا لو دار مصنع
العالم الاساسي الصين
صوره اليوم من قريه كفر عين في قضاء رام
الله حيث يصرخ الاب المكلوم انهض جواب
انهض ظافر حملتكما سنوات طويله الان
جاوزتم ال 20 صرتما يافعين والعمر امامكما
يبتسم لماذا تتكاسلان لماذا لا تمسكان يدا
بعض قماء البعض وتنهضى فقط هذه رام الرصاص
الغدر وانهضى او حسنا ساحملكما لكنها
ستكون المره الاخيره فقط ان حملتني قد معي
للمره الاخيره
ومن صراخ الاب في رام الله الى صراخ الام
في اذربيجان الشرقيه في ايران حيث تتسائل
الام عما فعله المجرمون بابن هذه ال 16
ربيعا الذي اعتقله الامن 10 ايام
والاهانه ليختار الانتحار بعد الافراج عنه
بيومين
لان ارشيا تجرا واطاح بعمامه رجل دين وهذه
العمامه
نحن نكتفي بهذا القدر في العربيه 360 ولكن
نتابع مع صهيب شرايير معه الان
مساء الخير
وخبر الساعه المباراه اذا التي تستريح
الان في هذه اللحظات بين ايران وامريكا
وامريكا سجلت هدفا على ايران في الشوط
الاول بعد قليل الشوط الثاني وفي نهايه
الشوط الاول كان هناك هدف امريكي اخر لكنه
لم يحتسب بسبب التسرب
السياسيه
ان كانت ستنتهي بنفس ما انتهت الى السياسه
اليك شكرا لكم